Let us look at this learning by the recalling cases a little bit more closely.
Implicit in our discussion so far has been the notion of most similar or
most closely resembling. But how can we operationalize it? How can we make it
more explicit? So once again here is a world of various colored blocks and
we can represent these various blocks back to the notion of knowledge for
presentation. We can represent our knowledge of these various blocks.
In a two dimensional grid, the width of the block and the height of the block.
So the blue block may right here, the red block here and so on. So when the new
problem comes along we may represent it on the same two dimensional grid.
In this particular case the new problem might have been represented in
this particular dot. Now given all the cases in the new problem we may calculate
the distance between the new problem to each of the previous known cases.
Once we have calculated between the new problem and
each of the previous cases we can simply select a case which is
closest to the new problem. This method is called the nearest neighbor method.
Now we need a way of calculating the distance between a problem, in that case.
One measure of the distance is called the Euclidean distance. Here is
a formula for the Euclidean distance. The Euclidean distance between two points,
x of c and y of c, which define the case, and the x of n and
the y of n, which define the problem, is given by this formula.
Now we can easily calculate the Euclidean distance between each of the cases and
new problem, and this table summarizes the distances. Given this table, we can
very quickly see that the case of the black block is closest to the new problem
and therefore one might give the answer the new block is also black in color.
So the nearest neighbor method is one method of finding the most similar case or
the most closely resembling case.